metro police finding human remains  inside a car happened near tropicana and  valley view earlier tonight  we do not know how long the body has  been in the car right now we're going to  be canvassing we're speaking with  witnesses on scene of when that car was  dropped off here  how long has possibly been here we're  going through that and they're also  canvassing for video on that the  department first getting a call about a  suspicious car this afternoon when  officers got there they say a foul odor  was coming from a white bmw the remains  were found in the trunk but there are  still many questions about what exactly  happened if you can help police call  crime stoppers